[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les points forts de notre lille c'est du
sang neuf
c'est vrai qu'on a une majorité
municipale qui aux responsabilités
depuis 40 ans et là on apporte une
nouvelle énergie avec des personnalités
nouvelles ont des sensibilités diverses
et qu'il y ait envie de faire des belles
choses pour la ville je peux vous citer
ludovic raul qui a des grandes
compétences dans tout ce qui est marchés
publics et dans tout ce qui est gestion
de l'immobilier
on a une vie rousseau agnel roussel on à
fuzhou moussa d'arriva tu mets qui
représente la jeunesse on a radouane
ouardani émail diallo qui symbolise
aussi tout tout tout le quartier du bois
de l'étang en arabe d'oum ibrahim qui
est sur orly parc
[Applaudissements]
le point fort important de programmes
dirais que c'est l'éducation
on a envie de mettre en place les outils
les plus innovants les outils
pédagogiques qui permettent de réussir
le soutien scolaire gratuit
l'étude dirigée des cours d'anglais par
visioconférence pour former la bonne
oreille avoir le bon accent mais
également l'initiation au jeu d'échecs
pour former à la pensée logique
mathématique à la la stratégie est
également les cours de programmation
informatique sur des petits robots
[Applaudissements]
ce serait la mobilisation d'une équipe
de médiateurs sur le terrain en urgence
ont veillé au calme dans nos quartiers
beaucoup d'habitants se plaignent des
incivilités ils se plaignent des rodéos
à deux roues ils se plaignent de la
saleté mois des habitants ont dit j'ai
jamais vu la verrière aussi sale et donc
tout cela il faut une équipe de
médiateurs sur le terrain pour
sensibiliser pour rappeler les règles
qui permettent de bien vivre ensemble ça
suppose des droits et des devoirs qu'on
respecte bien si on veut continuer à
vivre ensemble dans notre belle ville
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]